welcome to this video I'm playing
bananas from the US no game now no prior
game against the sky and I went to one
year for and I got the Scandinavian
defense which is um er not good news for
someone like me because I really never
studied this opening hmm ok Rena not a
frequent 1.e4 player so this however
looks strikes me as a little bit odd
that black is not doing c6 and now has
the Queen on b6 looks a bit odd but yeah
I don't know if I can punish it somehow
let centralized here maybe for possible
g4 it may be Bishop b4 at the right mood
ok so this he definitely prevented if I
go G form he has Bishop b4 i don't know
if this is a good idea maybe that's a
bit much but anyway why don't i can gain
some space IAM that is not so bad like a
bishop before I yes I thought f3 Bishop
g5 Bishop d3 that that it doesn't look
so bad with a quick maybe Queenie too
long castles and yeah interesting
hmm ok so interesting question now
should I take or possibly let him take
him with a move like win32 they are
probably taking us better and now we
need to for long castling next now that
seems ok for light I mean I'm not not
sure how good it is but it looks like an
okay position ok so if i can so long i
can yeah why not i should do that anyway
see takes Bishop takes so no problem
there I it's probably in okay shape here
I don't really have a quick attack on
his King interesting but Bishop b5 huh
he wants to play c4 but isn't that good
Bishop at three bishops e6b should be
too lets winning materia for me so
that's a bit an inconvenient now where's
he going
I probably has to go queen to see seven
walked with me Queen d6 maybe but whoa
what hmm I thought that is just wind
stuff
yeah in essence that I've got two
bishops here for four rook and pawn
which is very nice so Jake's and
probably no root yet I can actually take
on c5 so this smooth um bishop tanks or
up chicks
48 ago Bishop b5 for Bishop c7
keeps his rocks very much restricted and
he cannot play f6 some like here and
Bishop to b6 let's let's let's try I can
be a real pest here and try to win even
more tempe like this I just win one
temple with that it's not morbid it is
one temple so here the two bishops
completely dominate black black black
socks if they cannot move it's quite
funny switching over to f6 now that that
will be cool yeah you know I'm if you
know my channel and my I should pay our
fetish this is kind of the position that
that you want with your bishops
okay maybe I shouldn't have done that
but it's so it's a greater with this
thing on f6 so how am I going to play
this now p 3 and C for coming
what does he trying to do maybe look a 8
a-7 this kind of this kind of thing
now we threatening rookie aid okay so
that is not the way to do it I have to
do it differently if somehow
time morning probably I should have
should have played that a bit
differently not putting not putting this
bishop on f6 as good as it looks but
maybe I'm another setup would have been
would have been even better but
admittedly this is still a very nice
position
yeah that was an important little tactic
and once in a while I see a tactic not
often enough but sometimes okay
I my pawns I'm far too far too quick I'm
even just getting the airport if I want
and be 5 i'm also promoting with check
check
black resigns yo but to say about this
hmm yeah from here I think I mean black
is certainly okay yeah what is the
engine giving equal him that that that
was also what I thought that black
should be somewhat okay him I don't
really believe in that very much okay
Quincy seven is still giving us equal by
the computer yeah that looks like more
same decision if I'm doing this now ok
no problem no problem whatsoever but
this is I think it's just close to
losing yeah it is just too much the
bishops totally controlled blacks rooks
it's really questionable if I should
have been louder b5 here okay g5 is good
this is also good and now I should just
go c4 c5 be four and so on that rear
routing the bishop here to f6 was not a
great idea in this particular situation
his rooks are completely stalemated he
cannot move he also cannot move response
just just disaster yeah I was there was
a mistake I was 20 I was 22 much
attracted to putting the bishop on f6 it
still remains the winning position but
other the other way to play was a bit
simpler the engine is still on plus 3
it's a it's really not that as I did
spoil that much but the other way oops
the other way of playing was just easier
to handle you know after that it's
basically over yeah okay if he goes back
I just take the pawns here every
everybody every porn actually
so um yeah little some he shouldn't have
gone for that term for that change of
material distribution here with the rook
against two bishops okay well thanks for
watching